from a committee room on capitol hill
and beamed live on prime time the first
of a series of hearings to present
evidence to the american public evidence
of an attempted
effectively a couple
49 hours declaring a riot
[Music]
never before seen footage of that day
last january was released
all part of an attempt to persuade
doubters across this country of one
thing
january 6 was the culmination of an
attempted coup
a brazen attempt as one riot to put it
shortly after january 6 to overthrow the
government
the violence was no accident
it represents senate trump's last stand
most desperate chance to halt the
transfer of power
the committee seven democrats and two
republicans has been sitting in private
for months it's interviewed over a
thousand people subpoenaed nearly 100
and accessed nearly 136 000 pages of
records
as you will see in the hearings to come
president trump believed his supporters
at the capitol and i quote
were doing what they should be doing
this is what he told his staff as they
pleaded with him to call off the mob to
instruct his supporters to leave
in this first hearing we heard from
trump's attorney general what did he
tell the former president about the
election being rigged i made it clear i
did not agree with
the idea of saying the election was
stolen and putting out this stuff which
i told the president
and there was this too
how did that affect your perspective
about the election when attorney general
barr made that statement
it affected my perspective
i respect attorney general barr
so i
accepted what he said was saying
and the emotional cost of that day i saw
friends with blood all over their faces
i was slipping in people's blood
but in america's echo chambers who will
listen here's a hint cnn you will hear
that president trump was yelling nbc you
will see video of them abc all with
blanket coverage
but trump's loyal news channel fox well
they were dismissing it even as it was
live
but we're still talking about january
sixth
the hearings will continue through the
month